je vous lis je réfute ce terme d'extrême
droite parce que je considère
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un terme qui n'est
pas utilisé pour qualifier c'est un
terme qui est utilisé pour disqualifier
en fait c'est c1 c'est un slogan c'est
voilà c'est une injure mais ça n'est pas
une qualification
politique utilisée à bon escient parce
que je vais pas rentrer dans là dessus
dans le détail de ce qu'est l'extrême
droite mais parmi les deux grandes
définition en tout cas critères qu'on
peut retrouver dans l'extrême droite il
ya quand même l'autoritarisme et l'anti
parlementarisme
en ce qui me concerne et je pense
objectivement ce qui concerne le
rassemblement national
ce sont deux critères auxquels nous nous
ne répondons pas donc moi je ne me
reconnais pas dans cette appellation est
dans ce terme d'extrême droite bompard
alors d'autre part aussi concerne le
combat culturel
je ne dirais pas que la droite
aujourd'hui au sens large a gagné le
combat culturel c'est aller un peu loin
je crois et je les ai dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs que la gauche classe très
largement dominante dans la culture dans
les médias dans l'éducation
la dernière cérémonie des césar se sont
fait la démonstration dans le monde du
cinéma je pense est en revanche ce qui
est vrai c'est que l
il ya une forme de remise en cause
puisque aujourd'hui certaines voix
dissonantes commencent à apparaître
et d'ailleurs la gauche le vix
extrêmement mal parce qu'elle a eue elle
a tellement eu cette habitude de son
hégémonie qu' il est vrai que dès qu'une
petite voix commencent à apparaître
elvis a comme comme véritablement une
remise en question totale de
de son existence mais je crois que
surtout moins qu'une victoire de la
droite c'est surtout l'affaiblissement
de la gauche qui se fracasse face au
réel
[Musique]